We hear so many sounds in our surrounding in our daily life.
When a lion roars we hear a sound.
If we pluck the string of a musical instrument, say a guitar, we hear a sound.
Water pouring into a glass,
bat hitting the ball,
water hitting the rocks, etc,
are some of the examples of different sounds.
Sound plays a very inportant role in our life.
And most importantly,
it helps us to communicate with each other.
Have you ever thought about what actually produces the sound?
To answer this question first we need to understand vibration.
What is vibration?
It is "To and Fro" or "Back and Forth" motion of an object.
For example, if we stratch this rubber band with one hand
and pluck it in the middle,
it starts to move back and forth.
In short, it starts to vibrate.
It is that vibration, that produces the sound.
Yes, anything that vibrates will produce sound.
We will learn more about this in the next video
We know that the voice of adults and children differ.
Why is that that the sounds are different?
What separates the sounds?
Why is it that some sounds are louder than the others?
Why are some of the sounds pleasant while other ones are annoying?
We will answer all these questions in the coming videos
these are the points that we are going to elaborate on
in this series of videos based on sound
vibrating bodies produce sound
medium of propagation of sound
amplitude ,frequency and Time period of vibration
Loudness and pitch
Audible and Inaudible sounds
noise pollution and measures to control it
Do watch our coming videos to learn about these concepts and much more...